i know that everybody feels sorry for me
but we have so much fun what
truly makes an unforgettable movie sure
it can be the actors oscar-worthy
performances but a lot of the time these
celebs are upstaged by their epic
transformations
especially when those transformations
involve body paint
however having paint applied isn't
always the most comfortable experience
and these actors painful
onset memories will tell you why there's
only this much of my own skin showing
jennifer lawrence hasn't been quiet
about the eight-hour mystique process
she had to endure while filming x-men
and we can't really blame her
every woman knows as our dream come true
in the first film j-law had to sit on a
bicycle seat
naked while a crew of six or seven
people spent eight hours painting her
every day it's like a sleepover except
i'm
naked and being painted by the end of
the night she wouldn't even be able to
get all the paint off
to make things even worse she started
having allergic reactions to the paint
this finally convinced the filmmakers to
allow her to wear a bodysuit for the
later films
cutting down the makeup process from
eight to three hours
dave bautista may be a professional
wrestler but nothing prepared him for
how difficult
sitting in a makeup chair for five hours
a day would be after applying
prosthetics the makeup team would spend
hours trying to get the right mix of
gray red and blue paint
to cover the prosthetics and any
revealing skin
according to dave that wasn't even the
worst part
the paint was extremely hard to remove
and required an entire sauna to get off
at the end of the night
at the end of the day i get in the sauna
and three guys come in and attack me
with the help of steam pumping hoses
shaving cream hot towels and silicone
makeup remover
the paint would finally budge he's not
what you did what you'd expect
paul described being transformed into
vision as just
brutal although he doesn't enjoy
complaining and doesn't want to come off
as a complaining actor
it was a huge discomfort for him while
filming and the paint even started to
wear down and break his skin
however like dave the removal process
was far worse
he also had to have a portable sauna
built just for him to d-vision
to make things better he called it his
little magical cupboard and would bring
a beer in with him to pass the time
the whole process took about three hours
and i didn't think for a minute what
that was actually gonna mean to me
physically karen gillen's days on
guardians of the galaxy
started at 2 am because of her 4 hour
painting process
once the prosthetics were assembled on
her face properly the artists
spent hours making sure every part of
exposed skin matched the blue of her
prosthetics
on top of all the paint they also
airbrushed her with another layer
just to make sure they had everything
covered
another 30 minutes was needed at the end
of the day to get all that paint off
karen described it as claustrophobic but
when it was all said and done it really
helped her get into character
just like her on-screen sister zoe
saldana was on set bright and early
while filming guardians of the galaxy
it sucks to have to wake up at 2 30 in
the morning and by the time we started
shooting you feel like you've already
lived half a day
becoming gamora was done using green
airbrushed paint
and some colored facial makeup it needed
to be put onto any area of her body that
wasn't covered by her costume
listen to her talk about how brutal it
was
the whole coming together of gamora
every morning
that was a little grueling the science
of the 1930s was not in favor of buddy
ebsen when he took on the role of tin
man in the wizard of oz
he was painted head to toe in metallic
paint
that sent him to the hospital with lung
failure he was then recast by jack haley
who was instead
transformed by the paste version of the
paint however it left
jack with an eye infection and out of
commission for a week of filming
believe it or not rafe finds his
voldemort costume was mostly white paint
he'd spend hours in the makeup chair
each morning making sure his face was
evenly painted the paint was also used
to make his skin look translucent
and to draw on the delicate lines on his
face and scalp
although it took over three hours rafe's
treacherous time in the makeup
department paid off
even the child actors were terrified of
him and you
shall be dead gemma chan is thinking
twice about ever taking another role
where they need to paint her body
it's all thanks to the process she had
to endure while becoming
minerva in captain marvel she was on set
every day at 2 45 am
where she would spend 4 hours getting
airbrushed that was challenging
i didn't really think it through when i
said yes to playing a blue character
i'd think twice about it again by the
end of the film the makeup was even
starting to irritate her skin
congratulations for michael rooker being
yondu meant having
six layers of paint airbrushed on him
every day
he would have to get on set so early for
the three-hour process that he just
started sleeping right in the makeup
chair
he soon realized that others like zoe
saldana and dave bautista had to go
through an even worse process than
himself
and it eventually started to get easier
but the whole ordeal was still
tough you just gotta let it go you can't
fight it right
johnny depp dove right into the process
of becoming the mad hatter and
loved putting together the character but
that doesn't mean the paint application
was enjoyable
his character was done up using almost
entirely airbrushed paint
based on tim burton's concept drawings
the process did take hours but
johnny knew it was all for the greater
purpose of making sure his character was
the best it could be
we've all heard how intense heath
ledger's transformation was for the
joker
his face was covered in actual paint
while it was drying he was asked to
scrunch his face in order to give the
effective lines
the makeup process only took about an
hour however the grueling process came
while trying to perfect the imperfect
look
it took weeks of trial and error for
heath and his makeup artist
jim carrey's makeup process involved
prosthetics and a whole lot of green
paint on his face
neck and head it took jim carrey four
hours to get camera ready each day
the painting was so gruesome and long
that it caused jim carrey to become
irritated
and short-tempered with the rest of the
cast and crew
apparently it drove the actor insane
spoken
like her counterpart the tin man the
wizard of oz wicked witch actress
margaret hamilton was sent to the
hospital because of the paint used on
her
not only did the copper-based green
liquid cause intense skin reactions
but its elements also made her more
flammable and while working with fire
props she burned her face and hands
really badly michael keaton's makeup
in beetlejuice might just look like it
was splashed on but
very deliberate painting went into
making him look just as tim burton
wanted him to
his face was painted using a mixture of
yellow and white
and his eye circles were created using
brown and purple paints
michael says after a day of makeup and
rabid acting he went home
beat and exhausted ron pearlman's
hellboy transformation was a four
hour long adventure his entire body was
painted by hand including the
prosthetics
by his makeup artist jake garber it was
so
long that jake needed to make sure ron
had breaks in between to make the
grueling process
more bearable days where hellboy had his
shirt off took even more time
to get through it ron would tell himself
there are a million guys that wish they
were you right now
and there's absolutely no reason you
should ever complain
these transformations brought a level of
realness to the big screen that just
couldn't have been replicated with
visual effects the paint
literally becomes a part of the
character however it was at the expense
of the actors having
a brutal experience do you think there
was a way to make these celebs
experiences
a bit better thanks for watching